[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau journal préparé par les
équipes de tv 78 nous sommes le lundi 29
novembre voici les titres de cette
édition
25 millions de français éligibles à la
troisième dose de les rendez vous sont
pris d'assaut par les plus de 18 ans
pour le rappel vaccinal face à cette
forte demande quelle organisation pour
les pharmacies ou encore pour la
réouverture des centres de vaccination
le point dans cette édition implantée à
la place d'un ancien centre de
protection maternelle et infantile la
nouvelle crèche de là derrière vient
d'être inauguré elle dispose de 60
places et de 17 professionnels de la
petite enfance et puis c'est le retour
du dossier de la rédaction cette semaine
il est consacré aux violences faites aux
femmes focus sur le portail de
signalement du commissariat de
guyancourt dans ce journal
il pourrait revenir à ses capacités
maximales le vaccinodromes de saint
quentin en yvelines se prépare à se
réadapter face à l'afflux de demandes de
troisième dose le vélodrome nationale
pourrait augmenter les moyens pour
dépasser les 600 vaccinations
quotidiennes les détails avec nicolas
d'andré
ce n'est qu'une question de jours la
cadence devrait s'accélérer au
vaccinodromes de saint quentin en
yvelines à l'heure actuelle le vélodrome
nationale a réduit la voilure par
rapport à ces derniers mois avec
l'annoncé d'une troisième dose pour
conserver le pass sanitaires
les demandes affluent pour se faire
vacciner une réadaptation est nécessaire
il ya trois chances sur quatre pour que
ont bien sûr qu'on leur ait armes dans
les délais les plus d 1,6 prépare
mettant content qu'on a pas eu
l'autorisation bien sûr ne le fait pas
on peut faire 25000 vaccination parle
pas rose semaine eh bien voyez à près de
100000 part par mois ouvert du lundi au
vendredi de 9h à 15h près de 600
vaccination sont réalisés chaque jour au
vélodrome nationale vendredi dernier
lendemain des annonces du ministre de la
santé ce seuil a été dépassé depuis les
annonces du gouvernement nous
travaillons à différentes hypothèses
différents scénarios pour accroître
notre capacité vaccinale pour la doubler
la tripler ou la quadruples est une
hypothèse en discussion permettrait de
réaliser 1200 vaccins par jour et la
possibilité de rouvrir l'air central du
vélodrome est en discussion avec une
préparation nécessaire en termes de
personnel
entre les médecins les infirmiers les
personnels administratifs et d'accueil
et donc il nous faut recruter rapidement
le double ou le triple de collaborateurs
pour accroître notre capacité des rendez
vous en ligne pour la vaccination sont
ajoutées chaque jour pour le lendemain
et à côté du vaccinodromes de saint
quentin en yvelines qui a dépassé les
350 milles injections depuis son
ouverture en début d'année d'autres
centres de vaccination sont déjà ouverts
ou prépare en tout cas leur réouverture
on fait le point avec vous nicolas
landry bonsoir bonsoir je suis nous est
donc jeunesse pour tv 78 quels sont à
l'heure actuelle les centres qui ont
déjà rouvert et bien justin d'abord
direction le nord du département à
bonnières-sur-seine
402 sont administrés par jour et de
nouveaux rendez vous pourrait être
ajouté ensuite vous avez le parc des
expositions de mantes-la-jolie l'espace
gérard philipe de sartrouville le
gymnase richard mique de versailles puis
dernières ouvertures en date le centre
de conflans sainte honorine
cet après midi et cette hausse concerne
donc ceux qui ont déjà ouvert on l'a dit
mais il ya d'autres communes qui prépare
justement la réouverture effectivement
justin la réouverture des centres de
vaccination de vélizy villacoublay et de
saint rémy les chevreuse est fixée à ce
jeudi 2 décembre puis après morissette
les pisciacais pourront se faire
vacciner chez raymond sur le même site
de poissy à partir du lundi 6 décembre
la commune voisine saint germain les
prévoit la réouverture de son centre le
mardi 7 décembre enfin dans le sud
yvelines la commune de rambouillet et la
communauté d'agglomération étudie avec
la rs la possibilité de rouvrir un
espace de vaccination et puis il ya
d'autres acteurs qui sont engagés dans
la vaccination notamment les
professionnels de santé et parmi eux les
pharmaciens et on va écouter tout de
suite le président de l'uar ps
pharmaciens d'île de france renaud
janice hahn adjahi pardon à notre micro
[Musique]
moi je fais environ 70 vaccins par jour
sans compter les vaccins grippes une
demande très forte de vaccination
avec une augmentation notable du nombre
de personnes qui se font vacciner pour
la première fois c'est à dire les primo
vaccinant tout en ayant une demande très
très soutenue pour la dose de rappel
commune mendient troisième dose
de l'ordre de 60% des vaccins réalisée
en ambulatoire sont faits par des
pharmaciens on a un petit problème
d'ajustement de nos doses par rapport à
la demande
puisque il y à une plateforme nationale
qui gère le nombre de flacons attribué à
chaque effecteur mais qui ont un délai
de livraison de dix jours on voit bien
que depuis les annonces du ministre on a
une très très forte demande et donc on
va essayer de s'ajuster le plus
rapidement possible
[Musique]
on a besoin des deux circuits c'est à
dire la ville avec les médecins les
infirmiers les sages femmes les
chirurgiens dentistes et pharmaciens et
les biologistes qui ont cette activité
de vaccination et on a deuxième circuit
qui est celui dit qu des centres de
vaccination qui ont l'air de vouloir se
remettre en place
merci nicolas d'ombré pour ces
informations journalistes pour tv 78
[Musique]
olivier et veyran ministre des
solidarités et de la santé s'est exprimé
ce jeudi 25 novembre les français de
plus de 18 ans sont éligibles au rappel
vaccinal ça concerne 25 millions de
français les rendez vous ont donc été
pris d'assaut puisque au 15 janvier le
pass année terre sera conditionnée à
cette dose de rappel et justement pour
continuer sur ce sujet maria chin ali
bonsoir vous êtes avec nous
bonsoir vous êtes donc je le rappelle
directrice de la délégation yvelines
pour la rs ile de france donc pour
l'instant pas de confinement pas de
couvre-feu à prévoir mais par contre on
est en plein dans la cinquième vague
oui tout à fait on est en plein dans la
cinquième vague et donc pour pouvoir
faire face à cette cinquième vague il
faut absolument qu'on utilise les armes
qu'on a notre disposition c'est d'abord
de revenir bien sûr le maintien des
gestes barrières avec le port du masque
le lavage de mains l'aération des pièces
et puis la vaccination la primo pour
ceux qui ne seraient pas encore vaccinés
et le rappel vaccinal généralisé aux
plus de 18 ans est là pour ce qui
concerne en ce qui concerne les yvelines
plus de 900 mille personnes disposaient
avant cette dose de rappel de leur
schéma vaccinal complet on avait demandé
mario jean a lieu au centre de fermer
leurs portes au 1er novembre seuls 6
rester ouverts dans les yvelines était
maintenue aujourd'hui on leur demande de
rouvrir leurs portes comment ça se passe
l'organisation avec les communes est ce
qu'elles sont prêtes justement à rouvrir
et à remettre cette machine finalement
en route
quand on avait fermé avec le préfet on
avait bien indiqué qu'effectivement il
fallait respecter un principe de
réversibilité parce qu'on n'était pas à
l'abri de vivre tête cette nouvelle
vague on va connaître et donc du coup
assez naturellement les centres avec
lesquels on avait travaillé les
municipalités porteuses de ces centres
se sont fait connaître en disant
qu'elles étaient volontaires pour
pouvoir ré ouvrir leur centre donc là on
a travaillé sur un maillage du
département alors un maillage qui est un
petit peu moins
soutenu que
lors de la première campagne vaccinale
puisqu'on avait dit civil s'en
trouvèrent là on en aura 14 en a huit de
plus qui ont commencé à ouvrir ce lundi
et qui vont s'échelonner toutes les
ouvertures vont s'échelonner jusqu'au 8
décembre donc qu'on nous raconte 14 mai
par rapport à la première campagne de
vaccination on à la ville qui vaccinent
beaucoup on a les pharmaciens et les
médecins les sages-femmes les infirmiers
les masseurs kinésithérapeutes donc
c'est quand même pas tout à fait la même
chose et on a par exemple pour les
yvelines +2 83% des pharmaciens qui
vaccine
les professionnels de santé donc on va
en parler dans quelques instants je
voulais juste refaire un point avec ouh
là dessus est ce que vous savez s'il ya
une inquiétude en tout cas s'il ya des
inquiétudes qui vous ont été remontés
pour les collectivités de repasser leur
capacité maximale je pense notamment aux
vaccinodromes qui avait une capacité de
3 mille doses par jour qui aujourd'hui
est à 500 est ce qu'il ya des
inquiétudes là dessus est ce qu'il va y
avoir des aides tout il n'y a pas du
tout d'inquiétude on est en train de
travailler avec les collectivités pour
pourvoir leurs capacitaire possible en
fonction des besoins qu'on a réellement
parce qu'encore une fois le vélodrome
était effectivement à à 3000 l'injection
par jour à un moment donné mais on
n'avait pas la ville qui intervenait là
on n'est pas tout à fait dans le même
moment en plus on est sur du rappel on
n'est plus franchement sur les primo
donc tout ça on construit avec eux et ça
se passe très très bien et on fait en
fonction des disponibilités des uns des
autres et des disponibilités aussi les
professionnels de santé et des
administratifs mais il n'y a pas de
difficulté vous venez donc d'en parler
les vaccins ça concerne également les
professionnels de santé et du territoire
est-ce qu'ils sont pris notamment les
pharmacies vous en avez également parlé
à faire face à cette nouvelle vague de
vaccination
alors expliqué encore une fois on est
dans un département où la ville
participe vraiment activement et
effectivement je pense qu'ils font face
sans difficulté là les depuis les trois
dernières semaines c'est la ville qui
entrent dans les yvelines en jeu je
parle c'est la vie la ville qui fait le
plus de vaccination par rapport aux
centres de vaccination donc du coup
ils sont complètement capable de monter
en charge je pense même que ils peuvent
monter encore un peu plus parce que il
ya un certain nombre d'incitations et
d'appui financier qu'on leur apporte
pour pouvoir les aider sur l'aspect
logistique et administratif pour les
décharger de ses missions la donc nous
la ville joue vraiment le jeu et on peut
vraiment s'appuyer sur elle est-ce que
vous avez l'impression que les illinois
sont prêts à se faire vacciner en tout
cas faire cette dose de rappel au niveau
des rendez-vous comment ça se passe dans
les yvelines
ah bah écoutez ça se passe bien c'est à
dire que les rendez vous sont pris dès
qu'ils sont disponibles ils sont
effectivement pris on n'a pas forcément
une visibilité exhaustive parce qu'on
peut bien on voit les rendez-vous qui
sont créés via d'octo libre mais par
exemple vous avez beaucoup de pharmacies
qui ne travaille pas avec d'octo libre
ceci étant elle vaccine donc elles ont
leur propre système de de prise de
rendez-vous mais en tout cas dans les
yvelines on prend rendez vous sans trop
de difficultés vont évidemment depuis
jeudi c'est un motif
compliqué mais il ya des rendez qui se
libèrent et puis là on allait nouveau
centre qui vont ouvrir et qui vont
donner des perspectives sur le premier
trimestre 2001 22 donc tout ça va se
réguler
aisément peut-être pour terminer un mot
sur ce nouveau variant au micro des cas
ont été avérés en europe plusieurs cas
possibles en france on pourra pas y
échapper qu'est-ce que ça prédit et en
quoi ce variant est peut-être plus
préoccupant à écouter le variant il est
préoccupant par rapport aux
halles a transmis transmissibilité
pardon un petit peu comme l'était au
départ le variant delta et puis c'est
vrai qu'il ya beaucoup de mutations sur
la protéine speights mais adapte les
analyses sont encore en cours ne sait
pas non plus comment ça va réagir par
rapport au vaccin donc on est en attente
des informations complémentaires
on est donc en attente d information
merci beaucoup my hand chine ali d'avoir
été avec nous ce soir je le rappelle
vous êtes directrice de la délégation
yvin pour la grèce ile de france
[Musique]
anciennement située à la verrière le ski
là-bas des ménages et attrapes ce fablab
abri nation abréviation de fabrication
laboratory permet à tout le monde de
venir fabriquer ou réparer un objet avec
des machines comme par exemple une
imprimante 3d ou une brodeuse numérique
michael et demi d'euros et mathilde
frank ou un fab lab destiné aux
étudiants aux entrepreneurs ou aux
particuliers à prendre ensemble
l'objectif de ce nouveau lieu qui ouvre
ses portes dans l'ancienne école
maternelle albert camus à trappes l'état
d'esprit d'un fab lab c'est de se dire
qu'on est tous capables d'acquérir des
compétences de les partager aussi c'est
un lieu de partage de façon gratuite des
intéressés et de fabriquer ensemble
fabriqués grâce à des matériaux recyclés
les skylab est une association qui met à
disposition de ses adhérents des outils
et des machines en échange d'une
cinquantaine d'euros le site consiste en
quatre salles avec tout d'abord un
atelier couture un une salle
informatique dans lequel on va pouvoir
faire des formations une salle qui est
dédiée à l'impression 3d et à la découpe
laser et enfin une dernière salle qui
est dédié à tout ce qui est électronique
pour faire de la robotique de la
réparation de matériel etc le principe
est également de réutiliser du matériel
pour éviter de jeter plutôt que de les
jeter à la déchetterie ou à la poubelle
on peut recycler on peut réutiliser on
peut réparer aussi et sortir un peu de
la logique on le vit avec le black
friday du tout consumérisme d'arrêter
d'acheter achetez achetez jeter au bout
de quelques mois le site propose
également des ateliers informatiques ou
de couture
depuis le 30 août dernier les petits
bélier lois sont accueillis à l'arche de
noé la nouvelle crèche de la commune 60
places dédiées à la petite enfance dans
les anciens locaux de la pmi
d'établissement a été inaugurée ce
vendredi 26 novembre le reportage de
menadi poquet
ils profitent chaque jour de l'extérieur
cette aire de jeu fait partie des ajouts
au projet initial de cette nouvelle
crèche l'arche de noé accueille
quotidiennement jusqu'à 60 enfants ce
site fonctionne en trois unités de vie
une unité de bébé et deux unités de
moyens grands nous accueillons également
les assistantes maternelles pour les
jardins d'éveil ça permet d'avoir plus
d'interactions plus de possibilités de
rencontres des changes
quand la pandémie non permis 17
professionnels sont dédiés à l'accueil
collectif les assistantes maternelles
dispose des locaux et de leurs enfants
pour divers ateliers
les enfants sont accueillis chez les
assistantes maternelles et elles
prennent viennent ici pour faire des
ateliers
par petits groupes
les ateliers sont organisés à partir de
9h30 jusqu'à nous
l'arche de noé a ouvert ses portes le 30
août dernier situé dans les anciens
locaux de la protection maternelle et
infantile
la crèche a nécessité deux ans de
travaux on regroupe les trois crèches
que regrouper la ville la crèche de la
rainette la crèche canopée la crèche
familiale et on augmente le nombre de
berceaux donc on a 23 berceau en plus un
projet de 3 millions d'euros porté par
la ville avec le département saint
quentin en yvelines la région
ile-de-france et la caf
le site est aussi un lieu
d'expérimentation nationale avec des
travailleurs en insertion
professionnelle
je vous le disais en titre cette semaine
c'est le retour du dossier de la
rédaction il est consacré aux violences
faites aux femmes selon le ministère de
l'intérieur chaque année 210 mille
femmes sont victimes de violence 94000
de viol ou tentative de viol pour lutter
contre cette violence l'état a inauguré
en 2018 le portail de signalements de
violences sexuelles et sexistes au
commissariat de guyancourt quel bilan
trois ans après le reportage de mathilde
francou 24 heures sur 24 7 jours sur 7
les policiers se relaie pour traiter et
rés un maximum de victimes violences
viols ou encore propos sexistes en trois
ans la plateforme a doublé ses effectifs
pour répondre à une demande toujours
plus forte la première année en 2019 on
a à peu près à 6006 6000 chat reçu en
2020 avec les périodes de confinement on
est à dix mille cinq cent pour l'année
là en 2021 à la fin du mois de septembre
on a déjà atteint les dix mille
conversation donc on sera en évolution
par rapport à l'année 2020 on est en
constante évolution sur le nombre de
chat reçu le portail de signalement est
entièrement anonyme et assure un accueil
personnalisé à la victime la durée d'un
jet dure en moyenne 54 minutes les
conversations elles peuvent commencer de
50 manière différente des fois c'est un
appel au secours immédiats quelquefois
sont des personnes qui ont besoin d'être
mises en confiance justement nous disent
je sais pas trop j'ai pas envie de vous
déranger des choses comme ça chaque
conversation est vraiment unique et on
s'adapte à ce qui nous est dit pour
répondre au plus près des attentes de la
personne 51% des quêtes concernent des
violences conjugales 35 % des
infractions sexuelles et 5 % des
infractions sexiste des chiffres en
constante augmentation
soit parce que les personnes n'ont
jamais accédé aux services de police
auparavant et souhaite avoir des
conseils sur ce qu'elles sont vécues
soit parce que c'est pour elle plus
facile en fait pour ensuite avoir
rendez-vous dans un commissariat de
police et ne pas voir se répéter
plusieurs fois en arrivant dans ce
commissariat depuis 2018 le portail de
signalement de guyancourt a enregistré
28 mille chat la moitié à déboucher sur
un dépôt de plainte ou sur l'ouverture
d'une enquête dans un commissariat
implantée au coeur du quartier des prés
de montigny le bretonneux la maison de
quartier andré malraux rouvre ses portes
après un an de travaux en ce qui
concerne les changements le hall
d'accueil a été remplacé par un parvis
et de nouveaux espaces verts ont fait
leur apparition l'inauguration s'est
déroulée sur place ce samedi 27 novembre
à 17 heures et pour fêter la rénovation
plusieurs animations étaient organisées
atelier graff ou encore barbe à papa
[Musique]
à elancourt le salon du livre était de
retour pour sa quatrième édition une
quarantaine d'auteurs étaient présents
pour des séances de dédicaces
la thématique cette année l'évolution du
reportage du 20e au 21ème siècle célia
get on go et nicolas landry était sur
place regardez pouvoir rencontrer et
discuter avec vos auteurs favoris à la
commanderie d'elancourt dimanche 28
novembre le salon du livre organisait sa
quatrième édition avec cette année le
thème de l'évolution du reportage depuis
quand un reporter jusqu'au dernier
ouvrage littéraire des grands reporters
du 21e siècle nous souhaitons que le
plus d'adultes d'enfants et de petits
enfants se donnent la lecture est là le
thème était porteur n'a eu un film hier
soir sur l'épreuve avec juliette binoche
et monsieur bardy a commenté il ya eu un
débat gérard bardy fait partie des
auteurs présents sur ce salon ancien
grand reporter pour la fp il publie un
nouvel ouvrage sur le général de gaulle
le dernier livre que j'ai publié me
raconte de gaulle dans l'intimité de la
boisserie lorsqu'il a quitté le pouvoir
et lorsqu'il se retrouve seul face à lui
même face à son chagrin ne comprenons
pas pourquoi le peuple de france acquis
dit il il a tant donné a été ingrat et
il a écarté du pouvoir une quarantaine
d'auteurs étaient présents et ont pu
s'adonner aux séances de dédicaces cette
écrivaine à publier son premier ouvrage
les aventurières du ciel il raconte
l'histoire vraie de si grande pionnière
de l'aviation pendant les années folles
parce que j'avais envie de faire dans ce
lieu c'était vraiment de remettre à
l'honneur
des femmes extraordinaires dont on ne se
souvient pas ou alors très peu
et qui pourtant accompli de grands
exploits comme par exemple adrienne
bolland qui a été là le premier pilote
au monde à traverser la cordillère des
andes entre mendoza et santiago du chili
un espace g mais c'était également
proposé avec les diverses albums de
tintin
c'est la fin de ce journal merci à tous
de nous avoir suivi dans un instant
retrouver michael elle met d'euros à la
présentation de votre 7,8 sport très
bonne soirée à tous sur tv 78
[Musique]